Chris Christie
he's on the campaign Trail Chris
Christie running for president Chris
Christie was just booed
by an audience political audience for
dissing Donald Trump
all right we heard the reaction to your
speech at the faith and freedom
conference I assume you well knew you
were going to get booed when you started
slamming Donald Trump's leadership I did
hear some Applause in the crowd as well
but the booze were loud what what's your
saying say is the anti-trump message is
there any evidence that it's resonating
absolutely evidence is resonating
Jonathan in the in the race for less
than three weeks and I'm already in
third place in New Hampshire only four
points behind Ron DeSantis who's been in
the race for a longer time and is
supposed to be the co-front runner uh
look people understand that folks need
to take responsibility for what they do
and my message to the folks at Faith and
freedom which did get some good reaction
too but of course I expected the booze
that is predominantly a trump crowd but
they need to hear the truth too
they need to hear the truth too okay now
you know and I know this has been so
unpopular an opinion for me to say
all right you want to talk about Chris
Christie getting booed when he knows
he's gonna I've I have had a very
unpopular message for a long time but
I've stuck by it because I'm here to
tell you the truth folks and my message
is Chris Christie could have a moment in
this race everybody laughed at Chris
Christie they said he'd never get above
one percent I said he's going to have a
moment if I could bet on him unpredicted
I'd probably put at least a small amount
of money on it
because I'm not saying he's going to go
the distance I'm not recommending that
anybody put their money on Chris
Christie but
I I feel he's got a lot more political
skill than others are letting on and so
he's saying
I go to Faith and freedom I go there I
give an anti-trump message I get booed
but I'm doing well in New Hampshire this
is a really
important insight for the 2024 race
the Christies of the race
are having a little bit of a moment
Trump is remaining dominant
what is the takeaway here the takeaway
is not that you're going to be rewarded
for attacking Trump the takeaway is not
that the path to the nomination is
attacking Trump
the takeaway here is that the supposed
co-front Runner Ron DeSantis is
weaker than it seems there's a poll out
from NBC News you know about the
chrysosons I've talked to you about the
potential criticons right now
Trump is at 51 percent
DeSantis is at 22 percent
Pence is at six percent Christie's right
behind at five percent Haley at four
percent Tim Scott three percent of
vacant three percent even ASA Hutchinson
at two percent
how how has the movement been on those
numbers Trump is up five points from
April Pence is up one point Christie is
up Five Points as I told you would
happen
the big change here is DeSantis is down
nine percent Chris Christie is not
taking votes from Donald Trump Chris
Christie is taking votes from Ron
DeSantis
because as I've said from the beginning
the big trouble for Ron DeSantis is that
he is running in the Trump Lane he is
the Trump candidate his pitch is on
Trump 2.0 I'm Trump without the
weaknesses
but his big base of support is going to
come from people who don't really like
Trump all that much and so he's he's got
to be both the better Trump and the
anti-trump and that's a very difficult
potentially impossible line to walk
the people who really really want Trump
they're just going to go for Trump
Trump's in the race they're going to go
for the OG so how does Rhonda santis
prevent himself from from watching his
support just dissipate between Trump on
the one hand and the Christies and the
other candidates on the other right now
go to grillblazer.com grill Blazers
Grill duns are designed to do everything
from expertly searing your Meats to
lighting charcoal grills wood stoves
outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of that you would
need high power fire to use for your
problem this would also include cigars
as I have shown once or twice though
that is not recommended at home Grill
Blazers offers two types of Grill guns
the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers burns up to
3 600 Degrees it's a 30 inch flame is
for anything you need the big bad torch
to do and I mean anything the SUV gun
has a shorter Barrel perfect for
professional Culinary Kitchen uses from
gently caramelizing roulette or other
sugar and fruits to rapidly searing
steaks outside on the grill using the
grill gun may result in extreme Grill
Envy from your neighbors so user caution
is advised get your grill gun from Grill
Blazers today and let the grilling
Adventures begin visit grillblazer.com
and use promo code Knolls for 15 off
your order that is grillblazer.com
promo code nulls for 15 off your order
Chris Christie's big charge here in the
race is that Donald Trump he is just not
fit to be president
character is the single most important
element of a president of the United
States because you can't know every uh
every issue that's going to come across
the president's desk it's not a litmus
test with check boxes are in them what
you need to know is what is the
character of that person and frankly
when I I listened to Donald Trump's
speech last night and he had the
audacity to say that he got indicted for
us
now I don't know how it benefited the
American people for him to take highly
sensitive intelligence and secret
documents out of the White House to
Stonewall the government on returning
them for over a year and a half to
subject himself to a raid by the FBI
even though they had asked him
voluntarily to return this stuff and to
then be subject to an indictment which
is obviously going to be one of great
trouble for the country because no one
wants to see this happen it's not about
whether you think Donald Trump has been
treated fairly or Not by the media or by
elements of the justice department it is
about whether he is a man of character
who can lead this party to Victory and I
don't believe he can
I don't believe that Donald Trump has
the character
to be president that line doesn't work
anymore that line might have worked in
2016. and you might still say well Trump
doesn't have an admirable character I
don't like his character okay but you
can't say Trump doesn't have the
character to be president because Trump
was president and he was a good
president
he got Roe v Wade overturned he was
great on foreign policy he was great on
immigration until he was undermined by
his bureaucrats but for that the first
little bit of his administration was
very good on on immigration immigration
fell dramatically the economy improved
you can't say that this is an argument
from what is it uh
heraclitus I think said a man's
character is his fate and this was the
art big argument against Trump in 2016.
he doesn't have the character to be
president but he he does and so you've
just taken a major quiver that you could
use against Trump that's gone and that's
why the Christie argument is not really
hurting Trump Trump's numbers
generally are just going up or staying
the same
the argument Christie is
also as predicted Christie is going to
weaken the non-trump candidates in the
race defuse some of that support and now
you are seeing a situation and we're
just in the beginning of it anything
could change but you're seeing a
situation that is beginning to resemble
a situation like Trump had in 2016 and
2016. Trump just had a solid plurality
in lots of states and the rest of the
support was split up among the other
candidates and Trump took the nomination
now in this case
using Trump according to symbols with an
outright majority so it would seem even
better for him what is
what is Trump's message Trump also spoke
at this conference faith and freedom his
message was an unusual one for the GOP
this whole world is on fire this world
is on fire
before I even arrive at the Oval Office
I will have the horrible war between
Russia and Ukraine totally settled I'll
have it done in 24 hours
I say that and I would do that that's
easy compared to some of the things that
I'd get that done in 24 hours I know
them both
I know them both
as the Bible says blessed are the
peacemakers see that I will be your and
I will be your Peacemaker I was your
Peacemaker
this is a very conservative message
and it's also a very unusual message for
the last
30 years I guess of the GOP
certainly the last 20 years the GOP
message has been a little more
saber-rattling
there's been a little bit more we're
going to go in there we're going to bomb
them we're going to spread Freedom
around the world you're with us or
against us we're gonna go attack the
axis of Evil spread democracy wipe out
these different bad guys around the
world Trump is saying I'm Gonna Be Your
Peacemaker blessed are the peacemakers
I'm going to be a peacemaker in politics
as you're seeing the Democrats become
more and more belligerent Joe Biden's
foreign policy is just more war that's
what it is
and he's fairly open about that
he has prolonged the war in Ukraine he
in many ways instigated the war in
Ukraine those aren't just my words
that's flat Vladimir zielinski who said
that if Biden hadn't pulled the
sanctions off of Russia and if by
obviously Biden hadn't invited Russia to
invade actually said if it's just a
minor incursion into Ukraine we won't
really do anything about it that you
wouldn't have seen the war in Ukraine
but the but the Biden foreign policy is
let's have more war and let's manage
more Wars around the world the Trump
message is
no war I'm going to be your Peacemaker
he broke the mold okay and so even if
you come later and you say I agree with
that Trump message and I'm going to
implement that Trump message and let's
say you actually can let's say you're a
candidate who who is somehow able to
implement implement the Trump message
better than Trump is it doesn't really
matter
because
if you like that Trump breaking the mold
thing you're probably you're probably
going to go and stick with your guy
stick with the original what a great
clip that was I know you want more of
them you got to subscribe ring the bell
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time